artur palma and his assistant are taking
no chances
in this funeral parlor that he runs in
lisbon
they're handling the body of an elderly
resident who just died from coronavirus
palmer says he visits nursing homes up
to four times a week to pick up bodies
of those killed by covet 19.
more than 12 thousand people have died
so far in portugal
half of them since the beginning of
january
it's chaos it's really chaos so many
people are dead
there's no room for all of them people
should be careful
they need to know that coronavirus kills
for real
i have already lost my aunt my cousin my
father and my grandfather
portugal is currently the hardest hit
country in the world in proportion to
its population
on top of a nationwide lockdown portugal
has shut its borders with spain
and for two weeks no portuguese citizen
can travel abroad except in special
cases
before the closure there was some
movement in the border area but at the
moment it is quieter
i assume that people are paying
attention to the border controls and
respecting the restrictions
hospitals are severely strained with his
health ministry warning there are only a
few intensive care beds left on the
mainland
some patients have been airlifted to the
island of mandela to ease the pressure
the government's also asked for help
from germany which is sending medical
workers and equipment to help cope with
the influx
the situation is only comparable truly
to
to a tsunami in the sense of the number
of
infections that we are seeing on the
rise um
for weeks onwards and um this of course
then translates into more patients going
in
to er rooms which then leads to more
people being admit admitted into
hospital beds
and then into icu beds and sadly to
higher death rates
the government says the more contagious
strain of coronavirus from the uk
is to blame for up to a third of the
country's infections
but the situation went from bad to worse
as restrictions relaxed over christmas
i think they made a mistake at christmas
they didn't have enough courage to order
people to stay home for political
reasons
people still don't have respect for the
rules and for as long as they don't
understand that they've got to respect
the rules
we're not going anywhere but even if
rules are respected
the government's warned the public that
the country is facing its worst moment
since the start of the pandemic and that
it will continue
for at least a few more weeks emily sue
al jazeera